figures one of the production companies
on this movie would have three X's in
its name Wow under what decade this
movie comes from every 1980s New York
City movie is to start with someone
walking through a big crowd of people on
a sidewalk to a soon to be forgotten 80s
tune the story of the white guy chasing
the old white guy chasing the young
black guy will never get resolved until
they realize they love each other cat
call cat calling what are you what are
you gonna do in the general population
discount Nicky Roshi looks so human step
one and pickup artistry is to stare down
the woman and without saying one word
then leave the building nine and a half
weeks boldly explores the problems white
women have getting cabs who hosts a
dinner party with a tiny-ass children's
table have you ever seen a table that
seats nine this tiny also I can see four
lamps in just this one shot stupid human
tricks street festivals city with
millions and millions of people keeps
allowing these two strangers to bump
into each other defining everything we
know about math Mubi spends an awful lot
of time listening to this reggae song
which I'm not opposed to if I'm out and
about and getting to enjoy funnel cakes
but damn move on
oh sure Mickey work follows a girl at a
Jamaican Street Market in its romantic
prelude I do it in it's stalking every
time I see you buy a chicken stock
this chick is super easily impressed
when she hasn't even seen Mickey
Rourke's dick yet she walks away but
then we cut to a scene of them having a
meal and alcohol together meaning the
movie showed us tons of them exchanging
glances but none of the actual asked her
out stuff the only way this movie is
getting out of my doghouse is with an
ass load of titties this is the $300
scarf that she likes and that he bought
for her
hey that is some ugly ash be $300 for
this in the 1980s he was street vendor
said what you good God if I knew this
kind of behavior could land a woman like
Kim Basinger I would have tried to be
creepier when I was younger don't said
what you won or about what unfinished
chess take a hell of a lot for granted
oh I would too considering the stock and
stair job got you to agree to an Italian
dinner and you agreed to come back home
with it
there's no one to hear you if you call
down well that's not rapey at all just
goes to show you fellas if you creep out
a girl by implying you might sexually
assault her you can send her some
flowers and she'll immediately squeal in
delight like a schoolgirl who forgot all
about the applied sexual assault from
earlier private ferris wheel rides
dude blindfolding is on the fifth date
everyone knows this I don't want ask me
to leave sexual ultimatums
cat senses some strange human sex is
about to go down picks perfect time to
exit this movie is fifty Shades of Grey
away from being a porno also everything
I know about life tells me that if
Mickey Rourke blindfolds you you gonna
die
I've worn blindfolds before though never
for sex but I'm still certain that she
can see out the bottom of this lane to
narrow blindfold ice play also she
allowed the blindfold so ice cubes are
next and if she's into the blindfold in
the ice cube she might be ready for the
1985 Chicago Bears you throw as much as
you can at a woman the first time you
have sex whatever sticks becomes your
routine and that was the end of the
second date apparently the ice melted
she got dressed and went home he told
her stock you later and she smiled
appreciatively movie notorious for sex
scenes has gone 30 minutes without
showing me any sex scenes worthy of
notoriety or any at all really unless
you count the brief nipple shot in the
ice scene leering hmm surveillance
monitors ultra modern luxury pad with
nothing in it but a telescope always
always be suspicious of a guy who lives
in an apartment that looks like this
even if he hasn't already dripped
IceCube water on your tits while you
were blindfolded you have a lot of
these which is the perfect segue into my
uncle died watching TV my uncle died
watching TV that is funny he had three
TVs and radio he used to run from room
to room just so we wouldn't miss out on
anything why didn't he put all that in
the same room he died of a heart attack
76 Olympics that is also funny the New
York Stock Exchange News features this
extremely vague and useless data in
blood this man I felt obligated since my
penis has been inside you know why don't
you just hand it to me
watch basically John fulfills the top
requirements of most women and that's
isn't undec Rafi lyac man if it weren't
for the proximity problems I'd swear his
dick was in that box
what that box wasn't nearly finished
being open but sure whatever are you
gonna fuck her what Q now I need you to
put this watch to good use because in
five minutes you're gonna have an orgasm
involving Pop Tarts what the answer to
your question will require a charming
squat each day at 12 o clock you look at
that watch that could be touching you
well on Sundays at that hour I'm at
church but maybe I can skip the
communion Oh should we have censored
that cat head we just saw was that
masturbatory fodder we can never tell
how in the hell is she going to go back
to her co-workers and explain how sweaty
and disheveled she is not to mention the
gene I don't put this natural perfume
she'll be wearing Gill art I'm getting
off right now
they barely make it on this ferry before
it sets sail but more importantly why is
no one guarding the entrance and why is
a completely empty ferry setting sail
are they still away cuz they're obvious
ones that they are hi
so you're waking up your roommate just
to tell her you're gonna score is this
the etiquette you two have established
is she prone to walking out of a room
naked or something also where the hell
was my only the first night you've miss
do when you were clearly at your place
sudden roommate a sudden movie notorious
for its sex scenes has gone 40 minutes
without showing me any sex scenes worthy
of notoriety or any at all really okay
so John slice is a hard-boiled egg and
what does he put in her mouth a freaking
olive what happened to the egg also
olives cherries cherry tomatoes
strawberries champagne cough syrup pasta
jello jalapenos milk honey this foreplay
is lacking a couple of food groups
notably meat
slow quiet somewhat unsettling movie
about sex fetishes suddenly plays the
new beats bread and butter like it's a
romantic comedy or something it's almost
like what I'd feel if Last Tango in
Paris suddenly broke this song out
during the butter seat tonight own crazy
conception stories also sheet drinks
milk like a toddler and he still wants
to have sex with her also none of that
woke up Molly then here's a question I
have and maybe the audience does too has
he put everything in her mouth except
his sexy guy puts a disgusting amount of
honey on her tongue in one go
maybe I'm just old but all this makes me
think of is how difficult it's gonna be
for both of them to wash all this sticky
honey off their bodies when they're done
even if she somehow didn't puke after
that combination of tastes you still
think her full tummy is up for sexy time
now also meanwhile watermelon goes
shamefully unused during food for plate
movie notorious for its sex scenes has
gone 45 minutes without showing me any
sex scenes worthy also I'm really
beginning to wonder if any actual sex
has taken place yet this girl your best
friend's ex-husband did so on the first
date and then immediately AM bluntly
told said friend about it the next day
I'm being kind only awarding her one sin
for that I just want tonight them No
yeah but can you afford all the
groceries you need to have sex on your
salary this Ridge has no light inside
when open which maybe you dismiss as a
broken fridge if this guy didn't live in
the Starship Enterprise of ultra-modern
awesome future apartments
no one is tending to the needs of Kim
Basinger snooping I want you to face the
wall and I want you to raise your skirt
because I'm gonna spank you and Tommy
James and the Shondells hanky-panky will
play because it will be an amusing
hilarious situation you are kidding I'm
not kidding
still kind of hard to tell amazingly
though after all the food and
blindfolded spanking is unacceptable
sexy struggle nowhere during the sex
scene do we see a position that is
possible it's staged shot and edited in
such a manner that if aliens from
another planet observed it they would
not be able to define human sex but
would be able to drive a theory of the
existence of divorce typical guy he
finishes roughly 50 seconds after
starting holy crap she stayed after that
and got even neuter oh I see this
clothing store pattern themselves from
the map room where Indiana Jones used
the staff of raw in Raiders of the Lost
Ark Johnny I like this sexy chauvinism
love montage hey let's make a really
controversial sex movie but let's keep
cutting away from the sex or two scenes
just after it brilliant movie that is
notorious for its sex scenes has yet to
show me anything even remotely new or
groundbreaking or controversial
whatsoever
Samus you mean at the Chinese butcher
shop
you took one look at the woman buying
chickens and said yep I can put her
through all sorts of bullsh this art
gallery is so flush they can afford to
pay this one girl to chat about her sex
life while this other chick is knitting
mr. love girl is not paying attention to
her own relationship
stalking also stalking a guy you've
already given up the vagina to like six
times at least tardy stalking Astarte
phallic mastication also isn't this door
open we wider than the view we just saw
oh let her leave you mean the woman I
didn't see and didn't know about because
I was biting into a hot dog a minute ago
sure thing boss
would be like to be one of the guys it
feels like a thumb in your mouth hmm
my spidey sense tells me something
sexual is happening right behind me this
guy is correct to stare at this kind of
behavior in public oh I guess this adds
new meaning to the term junk bonds hey
oh hey man
pimpin ain't easy also what the an N
sudden rain he leaves her alone to deal
with thug number one because reasons
anal stabbing man fighting those two
homophobes really put me in the mood for
some hetero sex right here in this
disgusting alley in the rain okay does
anyone else see the Oh multitude of
problems for having successful
intercourse in this manner her legs are
just high he's still wearing pant that
guy is dry humping bricks right now
movie that is notorious for its sex
scenes that has gone an hour and 12
minutes without any sex scenes that
seemed remotely noteworthy will now
suddenly get uncomfortably sexy tetanus
sex next week gone crazy conception
stories
lifting three minutes of bed purchasing
also I'm guessing they have sex on the
bed or something we're just supposed to
laugh at the hilarious situation they
put the store clerk through but did you
have to spend three minutes on it and
not give us any sex to watch at all 47
seconds of whip cracking four minutes
stripping scene contains almost no
nudity and definitely does not contain a
lap dance about 80 percent of this movie
is Mickey Rourke looking off screen
toward Kim Basinger I don't think a lot
of this stripping is anywhere John can
see it
I mean Kenny what the hell is he doing I
guess we're supposed to laugh at this
humorous gesture but I say keep your
eyes on block sir
again once this gestures supposed to
mean I can't believe she took the
stockings off oh my god what a crazy
woman
this tops rainy dirty alley sex every
time long after leaving the apartment
the Joe Cocker CD is playing in
characters continue to move and dance
and rhythm with a song lyrics is that
some sort of clue that the movies
timeline has been going on now for six
and a half weeks also Henry even derive
the meaning of the title yet is nine and
a half weeks the length of time you can
stand being in a relationship with
Mickey Rourke finally this movie gets to
the real story of Elizabeth and the nine
and a half weeks of horror she
experiences battling zombie rednecks
also see you later taxi leaving me in
the middle of nowhere I'm sure we'll
have no trouble finding a ride back side
unless se you get on your hands your
knees and crawl across the floor are we
past that in this relationship they
should be doing more advanced stuff by
now
like breaking up no I really don't want
to do this but as a woman who dressed
like a man and bang my honey on some
dirty stairs after beating up two hobos
I really can't say no at this point hey
it's her ex-husband who also do
cover that staring at her for five
minutes is enough to get the job done
also during this scene probably
somewhere far away dr. David Banner is
attempting to hitchhike to the next town
padding the heads of strangers kids
erotic loneliness swinging also forcing
your girlfriend it is something vaguely
lesbian when she's strictly dickly
I will now lift my spirits about this
kinky relationship by attending the live
porno performance in the smutty video
store what are these guys in the back
looking at do they have any of you
whatsoever that makes this worthwhile
because hey free Kim Basinger huh I
guess all is forgiven then which turns
out perfect for him because apparently
all she needed to forgive him was see
some really disgusting people on the
floor of a back room the power of her
boners is strong he just stabbed this
guy is talking about the artist but he
could just as easily be talking about
Mickey Rourke's character funny how when
he does it he gets to bang Kim Basinger
when an old dude does it it's creepy
so she forgives Jon for the almost
threesome then goes to her gallery show
but then has some sort of panic attack
because reasons as she's supposed to be
still all discombobulated because of the
almost three something whatever said
stop oh they're finally breaking up damn
I should have done that nine and a
quarter weeks ago Wow
so movie notorious for its sex scenes
turns out to not really have any real
sex scenes
I guess the notoriety stems from how
prudish we all were when this movie came
out and decided to talk about sex play
kind of bum we even included this in our
week of sex movies so little was the
amount of actual sex in this movie
you
don't say that what you don't say I
didn't say I didn't warn ya well either
that or you're practicing to be a maid
at the holiday and don't touch my levels
now I got them set just like Allah
forgive me to watch I hid this
uncomfortable hunk of metal up my ass
two years
I don't know much about movies but if I
well yeah I'm coming they on this is not
so bad like this is about as exciting to
me saying this every time I see you
buying chicken this is not my book
what do you mean that's the bird this is
the birds yeah
okay